Szenario Ernstfall Deutschland wird von
einem Feind aus dem Osten angegriffen
Teile des Landes sind besetzt
nato-kräfte verteidigen den
Bündnispartner es läuft das Manöver eher
Defender 23 die größte
luftoperationsübung in der Geschichte
der NATO wenn wir eins können dann
können wir schnell
der Defender legt Zeugnis ab von unserer
westlichen Wertegemeinschaft der Stärke
der NATO und unserer Partnerschaft
unten Alltag und Frieden und am Himmel
üben sie den Krieg
25 Nationen nehmen teil davon 23 NATO
Mitglieder außerdem Japan und Schweden
die USA stellen mit mehr als 100
Flugzeugen das größte Kontingent
Deutschland stellt 60 Flieger und
koordiniert das ist eben keine laute
Übung weil es eine deutschgeführte Übung
wir haben die Verantwortung übernommen
wir sind in der Führungsrolle und das
ist genau das was mir die Partner immer
wieder sagen geht ihr doch mal macht ihr
doch mal gerade mit eurer Position in
Europa ist das was die Partner von uns
sehen wollen und ich denke auch der
amerikanische Partner will das von uns
sehen
die strategische Nachricht von 25 hier
Vereinten Nationen geht weit über eine
Übung hinaus
es geht um Werte und die Stärke von
Führung im Luftraum es geht um die
Bereitschaft unserer Kräfte und die
Bereitschaft unserer partnerships
[Musik]
Zeitpunkt und Ausmaß lassen er Defender
23 aussehen wie eine absichts- und
bedeutungsvoll gesetzte politische und
militärische Demonstration der Stärke
geplant aber wurde dass Manöver schon
vor fünf Jahren
ich habe diese Übungen 2018 das war
damals mein anderes Besuch als in der
neuen Funktion als Chef der Luftwaffe in
Amerika vorgeschlagen bestanden damals
unter dem Eindruck des Überfalls auf der
Krim und unsere klar wir waren ja noch
im Einsatz in Afghanistan gebunden dass
wir uns auch wieder fokussieren müssen
neben den haushaltseinsätzen auf Landes
und bündnisverteidigung und habe damals
diese Übung vorgeschlagen und das Jahr
2023 haben wir ausgewählt weil das in
unserem Übungszyklus idealerweise
hineingepasst hat
zufälliges Timing in der aktuellen
politischen Situation aber sendet die
NATO mit er die Fender 23 klare
politische Signale
jetzt hat der ukraine-konflikt oder der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
natürlich dazu geführt dass dieses
Manöver dringlicher geworden ist mit
Blick auf die Notwendigkeit das
Streitkräfte wieder zusammen üben und
vor allen Dingen auch die Luftwaffe aber
es verstärkt natürlich auch die
Notwendigkeit einen politisches Signal
in Richtung Moskau zu senden nämlich
wenn es sein muss sind wir in der Lage
tatsächlich auch zu kämpfen und Europa
zu verteidigen auf die Ankündigung von
2018 folgten für die Luftwaffe 5 Jahre
internationale vor allem
transatlantische Kooperation und für die
Deutsche Flugsicherung hieß es dass
Unbekannte planen ein Manöver ohne
Blaupause
wir wurden sehr frühzeitig von der
Luftwaffe informiert dass die Luftwaffe
dieses Manöver plant und wir haben
daraufhin mit den Vorbereitungen auch
sehr sehr frühzeitig beginnen können wir
haben auch von dem übungsumfang der sich
stetig erweitert hat sukzessive erfahren
am Morgen des 12 juni beginnt er
Defender 23 Tage vorher aber landen die
Maschinen der Teilnehmer Nationen schon
in Deutschland
Schlag auf Schlag kommen sie an
250 Flugzeuge 25 Nationen mehr als 10000
Soldaten ein Manöver bisher ungekannter
Größe auf der einen Seite geht natürlich
darum dass die nato-einheiten zusammen
trainieren können das ist eine ganz
wichtige Geschichte das heißt man möchte
auf der einen Seite gemeinsam gucken ob
man denn das was man in der Theorie kann
auch in der Praxis kann es hat zweitens
auch eine Wirkung nicht nur für die
Piloten und für die für die Air Crews
sondern natürlich auch das gesamte
aufbauende Infrastruktur das jetzt
stattfindet und das nachher auch wieder
abbauen das heißt die ganze Logistik die
trainiert man mit diesem Manöver auch
gleichzeitig mit das heißt man kann auch
sehen können wir das denn denn dieses
Manöver ist ja dazu da um zu trainieren
was würde im Falle passieren das große
luftwaffenverbände in Europa stationiert
werden müssen nicht nur fliegen müssen
sondern auch stationiert werden müssen
angeflogen werden die
Luftwaffenstützpunkte jagelhohn in
Schleswig-Holstein Wunstorf in
Niedersachsen und Lechfeld in Bayern
außerdem spandalen Volk in den
Niederlanden und chaslav in Tschechien
dann zu sehen aus den unterschiedlichen
Planungsgruppen der einzelnen Nationen
wie wir uns in unterschiedlichen treffen
zusammengefunden haben bis ins kleinste
Detail Dinge besprochen haben wie dieses
Räderwerk dann irgendwann mal ineinander
greift ja und das ist funktioniert das
ist faszinierend
hauptdrehkreuze sind Jagel Wunstorf und
Lechfeld in ihrer Umgebung werden die
übungslufträume Nordost und Süd
eingerichtet dort operieren die Flieger
jeweils zwischen 10 und 14 13 und 17 und
zwischen 16 und 20 Uhr
200 Flüge am Tag nachts und am
Wochenende wird pausiert die Luftwaffe
also die Bundeswehr hat die Übungsräume
definiert und man hat sehr bewusst
darauf geachtet dass es Übungsräume sind
die zusammenpassen mit den militärischen
luftwaffenbasen sprich also dort wo
Flugzeuge stationiert sind und auch dort
wo wenig möglichst wenig Auswirkungen
stattfinden wir wissen dass wir die
Hauptverkehrszeiten früh morgens haben
und auch spät abends haben aus dem Grund
hat man die
Übungsdauer bzw den stadtteilpunkt so
gelegt dass man erst um 10 Uhr beginnt
morgens wollen sehr viele Leute von A
nach B fliegen und abends später dann
natürlich auch entsprechend zurück dann
endet das um 20 Uhr
die Deutsche Flugsicherung hat Personal
aufgestockt das heißt wir haben alles
was verfügbar ist zu dieser Zeit in den
Positionen das bedeutet dass wir mehr
Lotsinnen und Lotsen an ihren Plätzen
haben um die Übung sauber abwickeln zu
können dennoch der zivile Luftverkehr
wird beeinträchtigt reisende müssen
warten Militär hat Vorrang da diese
Lufträume eben für den für die
militärischen Operationen gesperrt sind
bedeutet das dass die zivilen Flugzeuge
die normalerweise Deutschland
überfliegen würden über ausländischen
Luftraum dann geführt werden für den
innerdeutschen Verkehr bedeutet das dass
bestimmte zu bestimmten Zeiten
möglicherweise staatsverschoben werden
müssen oder auch Landungen verzögert
werden müssen Staat und Landepunkte für
die Kampfjets sind die Orte Jagel und
Lechfeld
190 Kampfjets 23 verschiedene
Flugzeugtypen Flughöhe
2500 bis 15.000 Meter
die Flüge gibt es nur bei
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und der Ostsee
schon am ersten Tag starten Kampfjets
Richtung Litauen der Einsatz
demonstratives Bekenntnis zur Sicherheit
auch der nordöstlichen Mitglieder des
Militärbündnisses
es wird eine ganze Reihe an
unterschiedlichen auch
parallelenoperationen geben das wird auf
der einen Seite die klassischen Übungen
zum zum Luftkampf geben also Angreifer
gegen Verteidiger es wird
luftbodeneinsätze also die Frage wie
kann man Ziele auf dem Boden angreifen
geübt werden es wird aber auch die
Rettung von von Personen aus feindlichen
Gebiet trainiert werden das dazu kommen
extra Hubschrauber auch mit zum Einsatz
es sind also nicht nur Flugzeuge und
sozusagen drumherum eingerahmt wird das
Ganze durch einen hohen Einsatz von
Transportmaschinen die das gesamte
logistische Material reinfliegen nach
Deutschland auch wieder rausfliegen und
stationiert sind diese Maschine in
Wunstorf der Fliegerhorst nordöstlich
von Hannover er bildet die logistische
Drehscheibe der Militäroperationen
die Manöver von Luftwaffen sind enorm
voraussetzungsvoll das heißt also man
muss sich nur die Flugzeuge rüberbringen
sie müssen das Benzin haben sie müssen
einen riesigen technischen Aufwand haben
sie müssen viel Bodenpersonal haben also
von daher ist diese Zahl von 10.000
Soldaten die jetzt da sind keine
magische Zahl sondern das hat
tatsächlich was damit zu tun das
Luftwaffen große Voraussetzung haben um
sie überhaupt einsetzen zu können
tausende Tonnen von Material wurden also
angeliefert und ein riesiges Tanklager
wurde errichtet mit einem
Fassungsvermögen von mehr als 2,4
Millionen Litern Kerosin denn eine der
größten Herausforderungen eines
Luftkrieges ist die Versorgung mit
Treibstoff meine Kompanie ist hier seit
der zweiten Kalenderwoche also seit
Anfang Januar 2023 hier im Einsatz wir
haben insgesamt 17.000 Tonnen Schotter
bewegt knapp zwei Kilometer an
Rohrleitungen im Endeffekt verlegt und
sind jetzt in der Lage 2,4 Millionen
Liter Kraftstoff also hier Kerosin zu
lagern das ist damit also mehr in diesem
mobil
funklage als eine Station
auch der Einsatzort von dem aus die Luft
Betankung der Jets geübt wird in einer
Höhe zwischen
2500 und 10.000 m Höhe diese und jede
andere Übung die Probe für den Ernstfall
dieser Anspruch dass Deutschland
Rückgrat sein will in der Allianz nicht
nur im allgemeinen militärischen sondern
auch mit Blick auf die Luftwaffen das
kann man hier unter Beweis stellen aber
man kann es auf der anderen Seite eben
halt auch testen und gucken was
funktioniert in Deutschland was
funktioniert nicht wo sind auch
Überlastungen durch solche
Manöver möglich also alles das ist im
Grunde genommen eine gute Möglichkeit
sich politisch gut darzustellen weil man
diese Initiative ergriffen hat aber
militärisch auch zu zeigen wo die
Leistungspotenzial aber auch die
Leistungsgrenzen sind mit Erde Fender
2023 zeigen wir beweisen wir und
demonstrieren wir die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit dieses Bündnisses
diese Übung ist im Signal gegen
niemanden gerichtet es ist ein Signal an
uns an innen gerichtet in die NATO
hinein sind überwiegend NATO Staaten die
an dieser Übung teilnehmen die Deutsch
geführt ist dass wir in der Lage sind
dieses Land und dieses Bündnis zu
verteidigen er die Fender 23 ein Manöver
der super lative eine politische und
militärische Demonstration der Stärke
[Musik]